[Music]  is she here yet  not yet mom no  then she's late  yes  she is late  [Music]  you're our highness  mommy  family are all gathered in the drawing  room they are waiting  [Music]  three days  that's it  they're getting quite serious about you  so stand very still and smile a lot  they know everything  [Music]  they don't  mommy what's happened to make you so sad  well yeah and there's ours there is no  future past and the present is the same  thing  [Music]  diana they can't change you have to  change  [Music]  you have to be able to do things you  hate you hate there has to be two of you  it's the real one  and the one they take pictures of  diana for the good of the country  [Music]  fight them you are your own weapon  [Music]  well they kill me do you think  [Music]  [Music]  you